quand on remonte aux années 70 on
s'aperçoit que le jour du dépassement
1970 était le 29 décembre
c'est à dire que l'humanité vivait
quasiment dans les limites d'une seule
planète
c'est le jour à partir duquel l'humanité
aura consommé l'ensemble des ressources
naturelles que la terre est capable de
fournir de renouveler en en une année
donc c'est le jour à partir duquel nous
aurons manger plus de poissons que ce
que les océans peuvent renouveler en une
année nous aurons coupé plus de bois que
ce que les forêts peuvent renouveler en
une année et surtout nous aurons émis
plus de gaz à effet de serre que ce que
les forêts les océans les sols agricoles
peuvent absorber en une année donc à
partir du 29 juillet tous les gaz à
effet de serre que nous allons émettre
vont rester dans l'atmosphère et vont
participer au réchauffement climatique
le calcul du jour du dépassement se base
sur un ensemble de données issues
d'organismes internationaux l'onu la
haye fao le programme des nations unies
pour l'environnement la banque mondiale
c'est une addition de surface globale
d'hectares qui sont additionnés à
l'échelle de la planète et qui
correspond à l'ensemble de ses surfaces
dont nous avons besoin
et puis à cela on additionne aussi tout
et surface que nos artificialisés donc
que tout que nous étonnons pour
construire des villes pour construire
des lotissements des supermarchés et en
plus de tout cela il faut aussi prévoir
l'ensemble des surfaces nécessaires à
capter toutes les émissions de co2 de
l'humanité pour pouvoir les compensées
et faire en sorte qu'elles ne restent
pas dans l'atmosphère on agrège toutes
ces données pour avoir une surface
globale nécessaire pour assouvir
l'ensemble de notre consommation
l'ensemble les besoins de l'humanité et
ensuite on la diviser par 365 jours pour
obtenir cette fameuse date du jour du
dépassement qui continue d'avancer
d'année en année pour émettre moins de
gaz à effet de serre on a des mesures
qu'on connaît moins prendre l'avion
on en a beaucoup parlé ces derniers
temps - prendre sa voiture individuelle
mais quand on voit qu'on a 70 % des
déplacements en voiture en france qui
font moins de 5 km on a évidemment des
marges de manoeuvre pour moins prendre
sa voiture on peut aussi moins consommer
de viande la viande fait beaucoup pesé
sur sur l'empreinte écologique est
encore une fois c'est vraiment notre
empreinte écologique est vraiment basée
est vraiment impacté par nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre donc diviser les
émissions de gaffes de gaz à effet de
serre par deux comme c'est prévu par
l'union européenne d'ici 2030
c'est un objectif indispensable et ça
permettrait de faire reculer cette date
de 93 jours c'est-à-dire trois mois
d'août la ramener au mois d'octobre
comme c'était le cas dans les années 90
[Musique]